[Music]
i've swung the charity bell before and i
can confidently say that businesses do
not allow you to stand directly in front
of their door and block customers from
entering
any sign of our bogey coverting this
loudly what was peralta's plan here
fire off a quippy one-liner and hope
judy didn't run if you're already using
diaz on the sting why not have her
located on the other side to trap him in
come on santa why are you so fat bowl
full of jelly shaming
but also once again why is the santa
part even necessary for this ruse you
knew where he was going to be just
hide nearby and then swoop in for the
arrest on multiple sides just
hide and swoop peralta hide and swoop
someone in the special effects
department read tree lights on fire in
the script to hit a blow torch in the
branches and blew their
pyro load to excess cutting paper with a
cutting board barely held aloft by a
rickety pile of books
this is how you lose fingers people this
football powder is a hilarious fake name
but the idea that scully would use it on
either of these body parts while sitting
at his desk is absolutely a sin
how about a guy who makes fake credit
cards how about this conversation
relocating to a room where sensitive
information can't be overheard by the
entire precinct
everybody shoot your guns in the air and
discharge them like you just don't care
that's not exactly how i remember the
phrase
but i can't take that it's clearly not
cash and i don't have time in my life to
return things
has she never received a cash gift
disguised in a larger box
always open your gifts and shake them to
see if cash rains down always
well maybe not in front of the person
who gave you the gift but as soon as
they turn around you flip that card and
shake it like you are broke
presence is like old people third base
false old people are having more sex
than you
my understanding is that nursing homes
are basically eating jello and having
orgies and often they're all out of
jell-o
from using it during the orgies this guy
go to the hospital
and give a hundred bucks to some doctor
to give me the exact same tape let's
pretend hitchcock is dumb enough to
believe that a doctor uses scotch tape
fine whatever but he leaves the office
without any tape he came
into the office for tape turns and
leaves without any tape come on
directors give some direction other than
walk in deliver line while displaying
shocking injury walk out
from rey to z this is a very bad idea i
mean i think it's a decent title but
presenting the font like that just makes
it look like it says ray z
which reminds me of jay-z's kid brother
don't get me wrong garden state of mind
is a banger but after that tapioca
incident 2011 you don't want to bring up
ray
my job rose's job and the fate of this
entire precinct all depend upon the
outcome of this task force which is why
the surprising
lack of police force during the failed
sting operation at the end of the
episode is so shocking
you would think that everyone would be
incredibly invested in the success of
this bust when their jobs are on the
line
i mean they do catch their giggly bigly
but also apparently lack the manpower to
cover all exits as judy gets away
again this choking victim sign has a
picture of a full fish skeleton on it
and two things
one who eats an entire fish with a
skeleton still in and two
if you're choking on the entire ichthyo
rib cage my energy is better spent
starting the condolence letter to your
family cause
you gone and i'm hanging on to this for
all to list a few reasons that this hair
dryer could be dangerous in judy's hands
but fails to be concerned about the
death art on the wall behind him no it's
just gonna use to draw my undercarriage
later
funny you should mention it because your
inappropriate sexual advances on diaz
have been drying up all sorts of
undercarriages this entire episode
all right we can't be too careful let's
go over the plant one more time and with
an earshot of the open door to the
bathroom where our perp currently
schemes
gps tracker in his shoe he is not
getting away from me again even if it
means putting my favorite hand into this
rotten stink boot
announcing your favorite hand when your
other hand is right there and can hear
you
also why put a chunky gps tracker inside
a shoe in the first place
find somewhere to stash it where it
won't immediately be felt by your foot
this thing is absolutely large enough to
be noticeable when his foot enters this
boot
lobster terminal no one should ever be
this excited about a menu
found in a restroom seizure salad with
tater tots instead of croutons
this is a sin for me not knowing that
was an option my name is dante
thunderstone
i stole my first car at the tender age
of nine you have to fend for yourself
since your mother was struck by
lightning while she was pregnant with me
she passed i lived some say that makes
zeus my dad
dungeons and dragons nerds creating
backstories the one and only
there's only one thing worse than finger
guns and that is finger blats
and the season cop like peralta should
know this okay okay all i have to do is
break into this car and drive it away
without a key
something wrong you should know there is
no way you aren't hearing every word
he's saying from that distance
this next part is like french kissing
got it
jam it in there and move it around
wildly apparently peralta went to the my
first girlfriend school of frenching
things
stealing nognog little christmas humor
yes the nog from eggnog used in place of
knock
this show has a lot of people slaying it
but brower may just be the slayiest so
for captain my captain
here's your sin off oh cool cool cool
cool cool
here's a gps judy throws his left shoe
but peralta put the gps in judy's right
shoe which he's apparently still wearing
you told me to my face that i made a
mistake and that's as far from brown
nosing as one can get
so brown toesing then seriously brown
nosing is when you have your head up
someone's butt but brown toesing is when
you put your foot up someone's butt
honestly it was right there and i'm
disappointed you missed it
yeah he has he just sent me this you
brought your department laptop to the
bar celebration
that's like a santiago move peralta
forgot he left his laptop in the station
bathroom after taking it in there to
finish die hard 3 during an extended
bowel break
you may also remember him as the room
service waiter i had you tip
so generously son of a [ __ ]
yeah and when he ordered the lobster it
was code for kyle to follow
doug judy is so smart he actually left a
few seconds of pause in his selfie video
for jake and rosa to have this entire
conversation
he's a mad genius
the fake santa claus lied did you know
that we create monthly exclusive videos
for our singing club members bonus
outtakes
i don't know peter meth is a hell of a
drug extra sins videos
strange things are a foot at the circle
k
and even member chosen sin commentaries
i love this
i love this this kind of of a sin
because it's just
it's so silly pick our next video and
see the exclusives at patreon.com
cinemasins or click the link in the
description below spiderman is not a
parade you do not need to stop traffic
for spiders
[Laughter]
isn't hers pajamas the kind that
dissolve in your mouth
ew no no charles
i know he has a strict no gift policy
but
i found a loophole exploiting every
loophole dodging every obstacle they're
penetrating the bureaucracy
i said no because drugs are stupid
drugs are bad you shouldn't do drugs
okay that about wraps up my introduction
check it out bit wonderment well i guess
the look i'm best known for
is blue steel what's that look like
i want to see what everyone got everyone
and how everyone reacts
poorly okay
i set the building on fire